following in the footsteps of names like
the late Christopher Reeve and Brandon
Routh Henry gavel debuted Superman in
2013 starring in the DC extended
Universe launching Man of Steel this
take on Cal L was quite different from
his predecessors his more thoughtful
somber Superman occupied a dark Moody
world but that in turn all DC fans away
many came to love cavill's approach to
the character which is why he continued
to appear in the dceu in future films in
the wake of Batman v Superman dawn of
Justice and both cuts of Justice League
cavill's version of Superman wound up in
limbo fans couldn't help but wonder if
his run was over as the dceu struggled
to find its footing then came 2022's
Black Adam where Cavill got one more
crack at the part in a post-credit
sequence one would have to imagine that
this was a sign he was back for the Long
Haul however as we learned on December
14th 2022 this won't be the case as a
new superman-centric film is developed
there's certainly an argument to be made
that Henry Cavill never got his proper
due as Superman and should continue as
the legendary DC Hero on the Silver
Screen however it's important to face
the facts recasting Superman is the best
way to go at this stage in the game in
October 2022 James Gunn and Peter
saffron were announced as the leaders of
a new division of Warner Brothers
Discovery called DC Studios the goal of
this group is to ensure continuity and
consistent quality across most DC Comics
based films and television projects if
gun and saffron want to keep the DCU in
order they must come to accept the fact
that with continuity issues retcons and
more it's past the point of fixing
therefore scrapping everything and
starting fresh is their best move this
means letting Henry Cavill go in favor
of a new Superman actor after all
Superman isn't just some minor player
he's Superman if they really want to
convince fans they're entering a new and
improved era of DC media it would be
counterproductive to bring back the
previous version of their tent pole
character to lead the charge besides it
also puts an end to this strange and
frustrating limbo Henry Cavill Superman
has been trapped in for years now even
though it's best for him to leave the
role behind there's no denying how much
Henry Cavill loves Superman he went
above and beyond to be the best version
of the Man of Steel that he could and if
the DCU wasn't in the process of a soft
reboot he could easily remain
unfortunately due to no fault of his own
cavill's portrayal just as too much
baggage for him to carry on under Gunn
and saffron now the cameras are waiting
at your ship for the world to see the
holes in the Holy yes the almighty comes
clean about how dirty he is when it
counts most of the films he's appeared
in have proven critically divisive
namely Batman v Superman dawn of Justice
many also stem from the now defunct
Schneider verse a string of DC EU
entries tied to director Zack Snyder
that according to collider Warner
Brothers Discovery has tried to distance
itself from in recent years the Justice
League CGI upper lip debacle and
dead-end Black Adam Cameo didn't help
either so is Henry Cavill destined to
never play Superman again maybe but as
comic book media has proven over the
years it's smart to Never Say Never from
Michael Keaton as Batman the Hugh
Jackman as Wolverine Legacy actors
returning to their superhero roles is
far from uncommon once enough time
passes the DCU Finds Its Groove with a
new Superman and a narrative opportunity
arises perhaps caval could return to
play the same version of The Beloved
hero we've come to recognize or one from
another timeline then again with cavil
no longer playing the main DCU Superman
that does free him up to take on another
role in the canon in fact the same day
his Superman departure was announced
James Gunn mentioned on Twitter we just
had a great meeting with Henry and we're
big fans and we talked about a number of
exciting possibilities to work together
in the future
could he be a member of the Green
Lantern Corps Bizarro that might time
will tell but hopefully he'll get to
sink his teeth into a new DC raw down
the line
[Music]
thank you